ja und die Welt sie will nun natürlich
wissen wer genau hat das Grauen von
Butcher zu verantworten wer hat hunderte
wehrlose Menschen hingerichtet Max
Giebel und Julian Röpke sind den Tätern
auf der Spur
[Musik]
ja die westliche Staatengemeinschaft sie
konnte die Menschen von Butcher nicht
vor ihren Mördern retten konnte sie
nicht schützen vor diesen russischen
Soldaten die dort wehrlose Zivilisten
ermordet haben Julian das wichtigste ist
jetzt in so einer Phase aber natürlich
die Verantwortlichen aufzuspüren
Informationen zusammenzutragen die dazu
führen dass die Mörder am Ende überführt
werden können und da gibt es eine erste
heiße Spur Julian denn das ukrainische
Geheimdienst Ministerium
Verteidigungsministerium wir haben eine
Liste veröffentlicht von einer Einheit
die im Mittelpunkt dieses
Kriegsverbrechen stehen könnte Julian
wir schauen direkt drauf denn das hier
das ist also die Liste der Soldaten der
motorisierten schützenbrigade die bis
zuletzt in Butcher stationiert waren
Julian ganz genau wir wissen heute was
verschiedene Einheiten über verschiedene
Zeiten in Butcher kann aber diese
Einheit hier wurde identifiziert als die
die in den letzten drei Wochen dort das
Sagen hatte und die Einheit und das ist
das interessante die spezielle
Truppenteile auch am Äußeren zu sehende
Truppenteile in sich hat nämlich
ethnische Minderheiten aus Russland und
diese wurden von verschiedenen Zeugen
die gesehen haben wie Ihre Liebsten ihre
Verwandten erschossen wurden
identifiziert und aus diesem Grunde oder
bzw das passt zusammen mit ukrainischen
Geheimdienstes Erkenntnissen das genau
diese Einheiten nämlich auch dort war in
der Stadt zu der Zeit diese Liste die
wir hier Vorhaben ich spiele sie noch
mal ab unsere Grafik hat Sie aufbereitet
die umfasst rund 1000 Soldaten junge
Soldaten
ältere Soldaten alle Dienstgrade und was
interessant ist die Ukraine die haben
hier direkt die Passdaten mit
veröffentlicht manchmal geht das mal
hier das ist diese Spalte warum haben
Sie das gemacht naja wenn einer dieser
Soldaten in den nächsten Jahren vor hat
ins Ausland zu reisen dann ist denkbar
dass er dort direkt an der
Grenzkontrolle festgenommen werden
könnte wenn es denn eines Tages
hoffentlich zu einem Strafprozess kommt
und die spätere neue Mörder aus Butcher
sich verantworten müssen das hier dieser
Mann der könnte im Mittelpunkt dieser
späteren Verhandlungen dieser späteren
Aufarbeitung stehen denn das hier das
ist der Offizier der diese Einheit
kommandiert hat und der womöglich ja das
ganze befehligt hat oder zumindest nicht
gestoppt hat Julian genau also die 64
motorisierte schützenbrigade ist eine
relativ große brilliarde wir haben
gesehen allein da waren tausend Namen
drauf die waren nicht alle im Butcher
aber ich glaube den Ukrainer ist es
wichtig dieses naming and shaming zu
sein zu betreiben also ganz klar zu
machen wir wissen wer Ihr seid und wir
wissen dass ihr hier wart wie gesagt die
Zeugen die wir die wir auch mit uns
gesprochen haben haben eben gesagt sowas
wie ja das waren verschiedene Leute dort
einige sagen europäisch aus andere
Sachen und dann hieß es Kasachisch aus
aber wir haben noch mal nachgefragt
haben wir noch mal nachgeforscht und für
diese Ukrainer dort aus diesen
dörflichen Gegnern auch ältere ältere
Frauen teilweise ist alles was sozusagen
nicht im europäischen entspricht und
nicht dem
mal dem dem kaukasischen entspricht so
aus dieser aus der Tschetschenien da
gestern Gegend was also anders aussieht
ist für die Kasachstan wir haben aber
dann nachgefragt und es gibt auch bei
belsat einem belarussischen
oppositionssender eine weitere
Zeugenaussage wo Leute gesagt haben dem
Anschein nach kamen einige der Mörder
aus boyardien aus der autonomen Region
boyardien im Osten Russlands bojaden die
wie wir wissen auch in dieser Einheit
hier der 64 mechanisierten Brigade tätig
waren es gibt ein Foto dieser Einheit
dass man es einmal sieht von was
sprechen wir hier eigentlich wir wissen
nicht ob diese Menschen auf diesem Foto
Kriegsverbrechen begangen haben das ist
ganz klar aber diese Menschen diese
Soldaten sind Teil der Einheit die hier
im Mittelpunkt steht und du sagst es
eben optisch unterscheiden Sie sich halt
vom blauäugigen blonden klassischen
russischen Soldaten den sie gehören eine
ethnischen Minderheit an aus Russland
und du hast es gesagt die Beweiskette
wir schauen auf die Karte ich stoppe das
ganz kurz einmal am Anfang denn diese
Einheit die kommt vom anderen Ende der
Erde kann man fast sagen das ist richtig
die Einheit kommt von 8000 km weiter
östlich der Ukraine dort wurde sie
mobilisiert im Januar im Rahmen der
Kriegsvorbereitung und ich finde es noch
mal ganz wichtig zu sagen wir sehen hier
viele bojanten die einen hat bestanden
nicht nur aus bewerten aber auch in
Russland gibt es sagen wir mal nein ich
will nicht sagen Rassismus aber
ethnische Differenzen das heißt wir
haben Fotos aus dieser Einheit von
Menschen die aussehen wie jemand aus
Moskau die sich in Gruppen fotografieren
und wir haben Fotos aus dieser Einheit
von Menschen die aussehen wie jemand aus
boyard sind die sich in Gruppen
fotografieren die müssen sich sage ich
mal weniger weniger oft als man es
vielleicht vermuten könnte und diese
Einheit wurde und wir sehen jetzt hier
Mitte Januar mobilisiert mit mobilisiert
und immer wieder fotografiert und
gefilmt auf ihrem Weg in die Ukraine und
zwar nicht nur in die Ukraine sondern du
wirst es gleich sehen genau in die
Region nördlich von Kiew am 7.3 dort
genau zu der Zeit übrigens also am Tag
bevor dieses Massaker stattgefunden hat
genau dort gefilmt an dem Ort wo auch
diese Verbrechen stattgefunden haben das
hier ist ganz wichtig denn das hier das
verortet diese Einheit am Tatort das
hier ist nicht ukrainische Informationen
ukrainische geheimdienstinformation
sondern das hier sind Fotos die eben und
Videos die in den vergangenen acht
Wochen zwölf Wochen entstanden sind wo
eben diese Einheit dokumentiert worden
ist wie sie quer durch Russland gefahren
ist diese diese Videos Julian aus denen
diese diese Fotos die wir hier gezogen
haben kommen wie normal ist dass das auf
tik tok und anderen Plattformen diese
Züge gefilmt wurden und jetzt womöglich
ja als Beweisstücke gelten können ja ich
finde es auch diesen Mix total spannend
wir haben hier einmal die Leute die in
selfie von sich machen bzw sich
fotografieren lassen vor ihrer vor ihrer
Kaserne dann haben wir eben von
russischen Passanten diese ganzen Videos
und Fotos wir haben das schon im Januar
besprochen das war sehr
ja also man kann halt ein riesige Armee
von 200.000 Mann nicht heimlich bewegen
durch sein riesiges Land die werden
immer wieder gefilmt und fotografiert
und was ich wichtig finde das letzte
Foto man sieht ja vielleicht diesen
Stern in der Ecke das ist nicht vom
Passanten das ist nicht von
irgendwelchen Zeugen gemacht worden das
ist von der russischen Armee selbst
veröffentlicht worden die russische
Armee die also stolz darauf war dass
diese Einheit nördlich vom Kiew aktiver
und versucht hat mittlerweile wird es
dementiert versucht hat die ukrainische
Hauptstadt dort zu erobern
was glaubst du wie wie kann sowas jetzt
weitergehen welche weiteren Bruchstücke
braucht man un am Ende einzelne Soldaten
womöglich Anklagen zu können was wird
dafür noch gebraucht du hast die
Zeugenaussagen zum Beispiel angesprochen
wie wichtig ist das jetzt ja also mir
persönlich sind bisher vier
Zeugenaussagen bekannt von vier
Überlebenden die gesagt haben dass diese
Menschen dort waren zusammen eben mit
den Informationen her russischen Armee
den frei verfügbaren Informationen
Informationen des ukrainischen
Geheimdienstes ergibt sich hier eine
Beweiskette die in eine bestimmte
Richtung führt
ich persönlich halte es für
unwahrscheinlich dass am Ende einzelne
Soldaten dort auf der Anklagebank sitzen
aber natürlich muss man sehen wer hat
die Verantwortung dafür und zwar die
militärische Verantwortung in der
kommando-kette wir haben vorhin den
Herrn gesehen der die Einheit anführt
das ist dieser Herr hier Herr omur
Beckhoff aber natürlich auch die
politische Verantwortung und da sind wir
im Kreml da sind wir im russischen
Verteidigungsministerium bei Herrn
scheuu und natürlich im Kreml bei Herrn
Putin die politisch zu verantworten
haben was die russischen Soldaten hier
begangen haben wir werden natürlich
weiter diese Aufarbeitung genau
begleiten und genau hinschauen und auch
dokumentieren bei uns wollen jetzt aber
noch einmal ein Stück weit in die
Zukunft schauen nämlich das was sich
momentan abspielt in der Ukraine und
besser gesagt außerhalb noch der Ukraine
denn du hast dieses Video hier
mitgemacht wir sehen wieder genau so ein
Video von Panzern auf einem Zug warum
ist dieses Video wichtig Julian ja
dieses Video erinnert uns an die
hunderten Videos von sich bewegenden
Panzer nach Westen bewegenden Panzern
die wir im Januar und Februar gesehen
haben wo damals noch alle oft dann naja
vielleicht sind das nur Manöver oder die
verlegen nur aus Spaß oder wie auch
immer am Ende war es Kriegsvorbereitung
und dieses Video ist nicht aus dem
Januar sondern aus dem Februar sondern
es ist von gestern es ist also von
Anfang März und wir sehen dass hier neue
russische Panzer unterwegs sind aus
Richtung Moskau und Richtung Jelenia das
ist in der Nähe der Ukraine und wir
glauben und nicht nur wir sondern die
von die russischen Experten vom ci-team
von einer investigativplattform glauben
dass diese panzerbewegung die wir nicht
nur in Moskau sehen sondern auch in
Jekaterinburg sehen mit einer
Mobilisierung von 60.000 neuen
russischen Soldaten zusammenhängt die
die Verluste die den Ukrainer in den
Russen zugefügt haben ausgleichen sollen
und für eine neue Offensive eine zweite
Welle im Osten der Ukraine bereit stehen
sollen das muss man vielleicht noch mal
sagen also in den letzten Tagen da haben
wir das hier vor allem beobachtet
nämlich den Abzug den Rückzug der
russischen Truppen aus der Region Kiew
und auch aus Gianni ich zeige das mal
ein und aus all diese Gebiete waren noch
vor einer Woche teils komplett besetzt
heißt teilweise besetzt hier sind alle
russischen Truppen raus aber wir sehen
eben im Osten der Ukraine überhaupt kein
Ende der Offensive im Gegenteil auch der
ukrainische Generalstab hat heute gesagt
wir haben weitere Gebiete hier verloren
die Russen Rücken an rakiv in donetz und
und du ganz weiter vor wo sind gerade
die stärksten Vorstöße wenn du das
einzeichnest also wo auf welche Region
schaut man aus ukrainischer Sicht mit
größter Sorge wir können einmal zeigen
hier haben wir Raki die Großstadt die
weiterhin gehalten wird von der Ukraine
wir sehen aber einen russischen
Vorschuss in diese Richtung und
vielleicht kann ich einmal kurz eine
andere Farbe haben aus Raki nach Süden
geht der Vorstoß und versucht eben dort
die ukrainischen Truppen die hier nicht
erst seit kurzem sondern seit 2014 die
frontverteidigen gegen die da
sogenannten Separatisten damals und
mittlerweile gegen starke russische
Verbände die sollen eingekreist werden
und wenn die eingekreist werden dann
wäre das ein Super-GAU und dann wäre
auch der Sieg von Kiew ja ein ein Sieg
aber eben leider nicht dass das Ende der
Schlacht um kein Sieg des Krieges weil
man hätte dann sozusagen hier den Kessel
von Donalds oder wie auch immer man ihn
nennen will aber der würde es eben den
ukrainischen Truppen unmöglich machen
sich selbst zurückzuziehen und auf der
anderen Seite Nachschub in irgendeiner
Form dort rein zu bekommen das wäre wie
du sagst den schlimmste anzunehmende
Situation für die ukrainischen Truppen
dort letzte Frage was erleben wir hier
unten im Süden wir haben oft und viel
über Odessa gesprochen die Möglichkeit
einer amphibischen Landung dann eben der
Vorstoß in Richtung Nikolai wie ist da
aktuell der Stand
aktuell haben wir hier eher ein ja in
sich entwickelt entwickelnden sitzkrieg
sage ich mal wir hatten zuerst den
russischen Vorstoß der wie du gesagt
hast bist nördlich von mir gegen der
versucht hat und deshalb so auch zu
erreichen das hat er nicht geschafft wir
hatten dann eine ukrainische Gegend
Offensive letzte Woche die bis fast
nachher son das ist etwa hier passt noch
Herr son vorgedrungen ist mittlerweile
sehen wir aber auch wieder russische
kleinere Vorstöße und wir sehen uns die
Ukrainer die Vororte von cashorn wieder
verloren haben sind also ein hin und her
und wir sehen Rosen russischen Truppen
die versuchen sich hier einzugraben zu
verfestigen und parallel und das ist
wirklich alarmierend sehen wir das
Russland hier wie soll ich sagen
pseudostatische Strukturen aufbaut
nämlich eine Volksrepublik herson
ausrufen möchte das haben wir schon vor
dem Krieg berichtet da scheint es jetzt
erste Bemühungen zu geben hier
ukrainische Marionetten und Lakaien zu
finden die also dieses Gebiet zu einer
neuen Volksrepublik wie die beiden
Volksrepubliken hier im Osten ausrufen
werden und damit der Ukraine ein Stück
weit ja für immer ihr eigenes Land
wegnehmen würden ihre eigene Region
geben würden Julian vielen Dank für
deine Analyse wir haben es gehört deine
dramatisches und ständig sich
veränderndes Schlachtfeld und auf der
anderen Seite eben diese Ermittlungen
gegen die mutmaßlichen Mörder die wir
natürlich hier in unserem Lagebild
weiter genau beobachten werden jetzt
geht sie aber erstmal weiter mit Bild
live